thank you for joining us America
Michael is with us in New York hey
Michael welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks for having me Dave appreciate you
taking my call sure what's up
all right I have $65,000 in the backend
I don't know what to do with it is there
something better I can invest it in
rather than just sitting it in the bank
with very little of any interest that's
a really really good question you know
what I have found over the years is what
you're finding number one I don't get my
money invested well if I don't have
goals for it and it tends to get away
from me you know just waters away just
kind of drips away so we tell folks to
always have an assignment a mission for
every dollar the way we figure out how
to do that is a system we developed
years ago called the baby steps and
depending on where you are in the baby
steps is how I would utilize the money
so the first baby step is a thousand
dollars saved obviously you've done that
baby step two is to become debt-free
other than your home do you have any
debt other than your home I have three
months of car payments that's it and I'm
done with that car it's a civic so it's
what is the fact that is the balance on
the car
the payoff about three months five
hundred forty dollars a month times
three months so it's a little over fifty
hundred dollars I would write a check
today and pay that off that's the first
thing I would do then that's baby step
two
baby step three is to have an emergency
fund grandma's rainy day fund of three
to six months of expenses now you
obviously live on less than your income
because you've saved money we know that
so what is your household income though
92,000 okay and so if we said your
expenses were five or six thousand
dollars that you could survive on that a
month if you had to in bad case three
months would be your minimum eighteen
thousand so I would put twenty to thirty
thousand aside in a separate savings
account that doesn't earn much interest
but is accessible as insurance against
life great grandma's rainy day fund you
know what I'm talking about
yeah you pick that number 20 to 30
minimum though somewhere in there you
can go a little larger if you want but
three to six months of expenses and you
see how I did that I said six times
three is 18 right yeah so I just made
this up on the fly but you could you
could get a little closer if you want I
don't care and then the fourth baby step
once we've done that and we still have
approximately thirty-five thousand
dollars left or thirty thousand dollars
left give or take 30 to 35 after so far
of your 65 that I've spent um or
invested or given a name or an
assignment then why we step four is
putting fifteen percent of your
household income away every year for
retirement are you saving for retirement
already investing for retirement already
yeah I'm saying a lot I have about two
hundred thousand retirement how much do
you put in a year um every two weeks I
put in 650 dollars and my employer
matches approximately 225 for a total of
925 every two weeks I'm not counting
your match you're at about 15% oh yeah
you're right at it okay so we'll check
that box and say that one's being done
in your 401k and your match is in
addition to that so you should be
putting 15% somewhere around twelve or
fourteen thousand dollars in in there
and that's about what you're putting in
twelve hundred dollars are you a month
comes out about fourteen thousand a year
so we're right there okay and so that
one's done you have any children no I'm
not married baby step five is to say
four kids college that one doesn't apply
check baby step six is pay off your
house early you own a home yeah I am I
kinda I was out three three years into
my mortgage how much do you owe on it
total I'm one hundred and thirty five
thousand okay all right I would throw
the other thirty or so we've got at that
then after we've got the emergency fund
in place and after the car is paid off
and both of those things happen today in
matter of fact all three checks could be
written today and then what I would do
is out of your budget any found money
out of your budget and you're a good
saver so this comes natural to you I
would do a little calculation and say
okay I got about a hundred left on my
house how quick can I get this house
paid off I mean you get that condo paid
off in probably three four years the way
you're going yeah
I mean that'd be a really cool lot yeah
hold our yeah forty-one yeah you'd be
sitting at forty five years old say with
a paid for condo and an emergency fund
in place and already got at that point
you'd have probably five hundred
thousand saved in your in your 401k
you're rocking man you're well on your
way to being a millionaire thanks
appreciate see that's how that's how
that plan unfolds though and I just did
it step by step by step all the way up
the baby steps maybe step seven there's
only one left and that's what the paid
off property max out all retirement and
investing and become outrageously
generous with your giving and because
the people I find that are the happiest
that are wealthy are outrageously
generous they don't give it all the way
but they just make generosity one of the
key things they program into their self
and into who they are Michael thank you
for listening ma'am I appreciate you
calling in that's a good exercise for
everybody to hear us go through hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you